avant de commencer notre feuilleton une
mise au point s'impose
beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs
s'étaient plaints des shadoks discours
était petit mondiaux je n'avais pas de
sens et par conséquent ça ne présentait
aucun intérêt ou éducatifs sont faits
éventuellement pour les chats les chiens
et les demeurés mentaux hâtons nous de
dire c'étaient les spectateurs là avait
entièrement raison et on ses preuves une
très grande perspicacité et intelligence
un château plus de prêts en effet
quelque chose de complètement idiot
voyez plutôt non plus bien quand ça en a
un c'est jamais le bon quant au coin
pulse culture et éducation
n'en parlons pas il serait donc injuste
d'imposer à ses téléspectateurs le
scandaleux spectacles d'animaux ou
hybrides
c'est pourquoi si nous avons cédé malgré
tout devant l'insistance des shadoks
reparaître à partir d'aujourd'hui sur
vos écrans c'est à la condition formelle
et express qu'il ferait un effort réel
et sincère pour développer leur
intelligence et relevé incident le
niveau éducatif et culturel de leurs
émissions
je donc l'ont promis